MINHAZ KAZI: Welcome
to DataVis DevTalk.
I'm your host, Minhaz
Kazi, developer advocate
for Data Studio.
In this video, we'll talk about
the Apps Script development
environment that you will use
to create your own Community
Connector.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you're not already familiar
with Google Apps Script,
its development environment may
seem quite different from what
you're used to.
When you use Apps Script,
you develop your code
in a browser-based code editor.
The code is a specialized
version of JavaScript,
and you don't have
to host your app,
as it lives and runs on
Google servers in the cloud.
We're not going to go
into too much detail
about App Script in this video.
We'll cover just the basics to
get you started with building
your own Community Connector.
If you're interested to
learn more about Apps Script,
you can check out the
Apps Script Codelab.
The link is in the
description below.
To start building
your own connector,
head over to the Apps
Script development
enrollment at script.google.com,
and start a new project.
An Apps Script project
represents a collection
of files and resources,
sometimes referred
to simply as a script.
In our video
series, we might use
Apps Script project,
connector code,
and script interchangeably.
Your project can contain one
or multiple JavaScript files.
The project will also
contain a manifest,
a special JSON file that
contains certain metadata
about the script itself.
We'll talk more about the
manifest in a later video.
Apps Script provides services
to help you develop your app,
including cache service, lock
service, property service,
and many other.
For example, the
cache service allows
you to temporarily cache results
for a time-consuming operation.
The service lets you cache
data at public level,
where the data can be accessed
by all users of your connector,
or at private level, where
the data can be accessed only
for individual users.
There is even a
DataStudioApp service
that helps you to build your
own Community Connector.
You can write your
code, execute it, test,
and debug all within the
Apps Script environment
without leaving your browser.
However, if you want to
use your own favorite IDE
to develop your code,
that's also possible.
Then you'll need to use Clasp.
Clasp is an open source tool
separate from the Apps Script
platform.
It lets you develop and
manage Apps Script project
locally from your terminal
rather than the Apps Script's
editor.
You can also use your favorite
developing tools, like Git,
when building your
connector with Clasp.
The Clasp Codelab provides a
overview of all Clasp features.
The link is in the description
if you want to try it out.
Now, let's say you have
built your connector.
When you or some other
user tries to use it,
Data Studio will execute
the connector code
on the user's behalf.
When a user uses a connector
for the first time,
they must authorize
the connector
to act on their behalf.
During this time,
the UI presents
a prompt to the user to
start the authorization
flow for that connector.
During this flow, the UI tells
the user what the connector
wants permission to do.
For example, if the connector
is fetching data from BigQuery,
it will ask for BigQuery's
scope during the authorization.
You can read more
about the Oauth process
and the Oauth scopes at the
link in the description.
This overview of
Apps Script should
help you to get started with
building your own connector.
You can always go
to a developer site
at
developers.google.com/datastudio
for more information.
If you liked this video,
stay tuned on the GCP channel
for more Data Studio content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]